Democrats panic over independent
candidates Venezuela approaches chaos
and Virginia is now pushing a hard left
abortion policy I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show man we have a lot
to get to today a lot in the news people
very angry on the Democratic side of the
aisle at Howard Schultz and quick note
you know there's a lot of news today out
about these so suppose a wage gap
between men and women quick shout out to
my wife we stayed up all night long with
my daughter she has the flu and the
cough and my wife being an actual phonus
actually stayed up all night long with
my daughter because she is the best wife
in the world so shout out to you honey I
never do that on the show but you
deserve it this morning we'll get to all
of the actual news in just one second
but first let me talk about what I'm
gonna do for my wife today I'm gonna
order her a batch from 1-800 flowers
because if you are in a relationship and
there are a couple important dates that
you have to remember there's Valentine's
Day birthdays anniversaries or the day
after your wife stays up all night
taking care of your sick kids so you can
get a little bit of sleep when you are
looking for the biggest and best quality
roses out there check out my friends at
1-800 flowers calm right now you can get
18 red roses for $29.99 or upgrade to 24
red roses for 10 bucks more this is an
amazing offer from 1-800 flowers 18 red
roses for 21 $29.99 or upgrade to 24 red
roses for $10 more the roses are just
beautiful I mean I got some for my life
actually yesterday and they're really
spectacular looking 18 red roses again
$29.99 or upgrade to 24 red roses for
$10 more and these things really lasts I
mean once you get the roses from 1-800
flowers they do last they're picked at
they're at the peak and then they are
shipped directly to you so they don't
lose any of the quality or freshness
pick your delivery date let 1-800
flowers handle all the rest when it
comes to life special occasions don't
settle for less than 1-800 flowers
at.com
again when you go to 1-800 flowers calm
and use 1-800 flowers calm / Shapiro's
then you get that special deal 18 red
roses for $29.99 or 24 red roses for 10
bucks more than that 8 1-800 flowers
calm
Shapiro's hurry that offer expires today
so go check that out right now 1-800
flowers that come in great company ok so
Democrats are in a state of sheer panic
over Howard Schultz which is amazing the
guy is not exactly lighting up the world
with his charisma
and good looks he's not George Clooney
Howard Schultz he's a former CEO of
Starbucks a large coffee chain that most
people have at least mixed feelings
about and yet he is scaring the devil
out of Democrats I mean they are scared
of him and they're scared of Michael
Bloomberg - they're scared more of
Schultz than Bloomberg because Bloomberg
has suggested he's gonna run as a
Democrat in the Democratic primaries and
they figure he's not gonna go anywhere
in the Democratic primaries there's just
no real chance that he ends up doing
anything spectacular there he's not
intersectional enough he's too moderate
so they figure okay we'll get rid of him
the same way we got rid of Jim Webb in
he'll just sort of fade out into the
distance of his own accord but somebody
running as an independent changes the
math pretty radically and Democrats are
really scared of Schultz which is why
you are seeing the virulent reaction to
Schultz many people are angry at him
people aren't people are so angry at him
that he went on MSNBC this morning and
he said like I've never seen the vitriol
like this which suggests that as we in
the political business like to say
you're not taking flak unless you're
over the target well this has led some
members of the media to try to hit
Schultz with gotcha questions so the
line of attack on Schultz is going to be
that he is a delusional billionaire that
he happens to be extraordinarily rich
and that's the only reason he's
considering running and because he is
both delusional and a billionaire that
means he is out of touch he's out of
touch with the common American person no
let me just explain at the top the
number of politicians who are really in
touch with the common American in
Washington DC is zero there are no
politicians in Washington DC that you
know or I know who are really in touch
with the common man people who you know
actually have to scrape to save for for
a box of Cheerios for example the number
of Congress people who actually know how
much of a box of Cheerios cost is zero
because they have aides you do all their
shopping for them I mean Hillary Clinton
as of 2016 had not driven herself
anywhere in two decades and she admitted
that Donald Trump plasters his toilets
in gold the people that are up at six or
at the top levels are not people who are
scrimping and saving with the with the
coupon saver in order to make the bills
that month and yet Howard Schultz is the
one being dragged across the across the
room for it so Howard Schultz dawn
morning Joe you'll recall morning Joe
from such from such special events has
we love Donald Trump and will make him
president and then we will turn around
and crap all over him
well now they're going directly after
Howard Schultz they decided to
a real gotcha questions our jolts the
question being how much does a box of
Cheerios cost I will be a leader of the
country of all American people that
people will trust and admire because I
will understand I have walked in their
shoes I'm on both sides of the equation
I'm somebody who has been was successful
I'm somebody who came from the projects
and I understand the American people how
much does an 18 ounce box of Cheerios
cost in 18 ounce box of materials like
budgets for the VA we don't ask you
questions I'm sorry okay okay so that is
a sure gotcha question I sure got your
question how much does a box of Cheerios
cost and this is supposed to show that
he's out of touch this is the same
routine that the media did with George
HW Bush in 1991 when they suggested that
he didn't know how a supermarket
checkout scanner worked even though he
knew perfectly well how a supermarket
checkout scanner worked by the way
there's something ironic about Joe
Scarborough and Mika Brzezinski grilling
Howard Schultz over his lack of being in
touch with the common man I will remind
you that Joe and Mika were Wed at the
National Archives which by the way is
illegal okay except for John mica no one
has ever been wet at the National
Archives which is a government site they
were married at the National Archives
becoming the first couple ever to Wed at
the National Archives they became
engaged in 2017 during a trip to France
these are these are common folks the
people standing up for the common man
they're gonna tell you how much it costs
in podunk Iowa for a box of Cheerios but
Howard Schultz that guy over there he
can't the wedding by the way was kept
under wraps it was purposely held on
Thanksgiving weekend when Washington
movers and shakers were out of town
according to Vanity Fair which covered
the wedding the ceremony was officiated
by representative Elijah Cummings
another person in touch with the common
man held in the Camaro Tunde in front of
the Constitution Declaration of
Independence and Bill of Rights so yes
I'm sure that these are the people who
aren't going to be the police for the
common man so you can see the ire at
Shults mean people are seriously
seriously angry at Howard Shelton the
reason that people are angry at Howard
Schultz is because Howard Schultz has
the temerity to believe that there may
be a centrist road to the presidency or
at the very least that Democrats have
swiveled it too far to the left nobody
the right is an great Howard Schultz
today nobody on the right is upset at
Howard Charles now Howard Schultz may in
fact take suburban of votes away from
Donald Trump in the end but they're not
a lot of Republicans hang great Howard
Schultz why because the more in the more
the merrier I mean when it comes to
people who are running on non insane
platforms I'm basically glad to see it
I'm not planning to vote for Howard
Schultz in the 2020 election but I do
like the idea that there's more than one
candidate standing against the idea that
we should completely nationalize the
healthcare industry for goodness sake
nonetheless Howard Schultz being dragged
around by his ear because he's rich and
we were now in a time of open class
warfare if you're rich
Howard Schultz by the way did not start
off rich and there's a person who
started off as he says in the projects
and now he's a very wealthy man he's a
billionaire now but we have to rip him
down because he's very wealthy people
were tweeting out the percentage of
money that he gave to charity this year
neglecting of course how much he already
paid to the federal government in taxes
this year I give a fair amount of money
to charity by percentage of my income it
probably isn't high enough and I'd like
to give more next year it is also true
that my effective tax rate is well over
40 percent because I live in California
the same thing I'm sure is true of
people like Howard Schultz in any case
whenever Howard Schultz says things that
are eminently true like you can't buy
our way to the presidency people get
very angry with him because he's rich
now we're gonna ignore the fact that
Elizabeth Warren has a net worth of
somewhere between 10 and 18 million
dollars we're going to ignore the fact
that Bernie Sanders is by any global
standard extraordinarily wealthy the man
owns three homes including two vacation
homes we're gonna pretend that Kamala
Harris is not a pretty wealthy woman
hang it come out Harrison worth some
money Howard Schultz though he's
different he's different so here is
Meghan McCain going after Howard Schultz
and Howard Schultz saying listen you
can't buy the presidency and the
audience booing him as long as you're a
billionaire you can run for anything and
my problem with politics right now is
the influence of money and no shade at
you but you do have to be a billionaire
to run as an independent that's why
Michael Bloomberg together example you
get well you but you can't you can't buy
the presidency the American people are
gonna decide but let me just make one
point
can I make one can I I love that do the
joy Behar's laughing ahahahaha was
Barack Obama a super rich guy who bought
his way to the presidency I love all
these rich people sitting around on the
side of the view every person on that
set is wealthy every single person who
is sitting behind that desk on that set
is inordinately wealthy and they're
sitting there laughing at the idea that
you can't buy the presidency here's the
reality you can't buy the presidency
Hillary Clinton spend a fortune on
political advertising and she lost
Donald Trump self-funded part of his
campaign but he didn't really buy his
way to the presidency the media handed
him an enormous amount of free political
coverage there's this weird idea out
there it's really amazing to me there's
this weird idea that if you spend more
money you are inevitably going to win
elections that is obviously not true
it's simply not true
if you run a good campaign you can still
win elections even if you are not
spending the most money in fact with the
rise of social media it is certainly
true that spending great amounts of
money in the wrong places are not going
to help you at all but here's the
reality people aren't angry at Schultz
because it's a billionaire the reason
people are angry Schultz is because
Schultz is saying reasonable things and
Democrats aren't allowed to say
reasonable things because that
humiliates other Democrats who are not
saying reasonable things so yesterday
here was Howard Schultz slamming Kamala
Harris over her idiotic notion that we
should nationalize the entire healthcare
industry he just played senator Harris
is saying she wants to abolish the
insurance industry that's that's not
correct that's not American what's next
what what industry are we going to
abolish next the coffee industry okay
and he's exactly right about this but
this is the real reason that Democrats
are angry at him because he said a
reasonable thing because he said a
reasonable thing right and this is why
then look what the Democrats want is
they want him to run inside the
Democratic primary so that the radicals
can sideline him that's what they would
like they would like for there to be
only two options on your ballot Donald
Trump and a radical radical Democrat Tom
Perez is saying as much anytime Perez's
the head of the DNC and he says you know
what Schulz shouldn't run as an
independent he should run as a Democrat
so we can sideline him of course I have
respect for Howard Schultz if he chooses
to get in the race I hope he gets in the
Democratic Party we'll we'll treat him
very fairly clearly saying he's not
though well well what I tend to agree
again Mayor Bloomberg I think it was who
said I've studied in depend
runs and and what an independent run
would do in 2020 is simply split the
anti-trump vote and help Donald Trump
get reelected and and Howard Schultz
himself said I'm only gonna run if
there's a real pathway to victory I'll
mark you being a spoiler okay well again
Democrats are deathly afraid of this
because they've taxed too far to the
left they know they have tact too far to
the left and they're scared so they're
their real goal here is to have Schultz
run inside the Democratic Party so that
they can sideline him right and that's
what they are doing with with Michael
Bloomberg we'll get to Bloomberg in just
one second first let's talk about your
hair losing your hair sucks okay I know
it runs in my family you don't realize
how much you care about your hair until
you start losing it which is why you
should be using keeps the easiest and
most affordable way to keep the hair
that you have these fda-approved
products used to cost so much but now
thanks to keeps they're finally
inexpensive and easy to get for five
minutes now in just a buck a day you're
never gonna have to worry about hair
loss again getting started with keeps is
really easy sign up takes less than five
minutes just answer a few questions snap
some photos of your hair a licensed
physician will then review your
information online and recommend the
right treatment for you it is then
shipped right to your door every three
months keeps offers generic versions and
the only two fda-approved hair loss
products out there some of you probably
tried them before but you've probably
never gotten them for this price keeps
is only ten bucks to 35 bucks a month
plus right now you can get your first
month for free which is a hell of a deal
forgetting to keep your hair to receive
your first month first month of
treatment for free go to keeps calm
slash pen that is ke EPS calm slash men
once again free month of treatment at
keeps calm slash men keeps hair today
hair tomorrow
you're not gonna realize how much you
like your hair until it's gone so go
make sure that you keep your hair today
at ke e PS comm slash men's get your
first month of treatment for free keeps
calm all right so these Democrats want
to keep the moderates who would run for
independent inside the Democratic Party
not because they actually want them
there but because it gives them the ease
of sidelining them now Michael Bloomberg
the former New York Mayor who was in
favor of a soda tax most famously and
he's very anti-gun he's going to run
presumably inside the Democratic primary
he's saying many of the same things the
the cheolsu saying but he's not
receiving quite the same IRC here's
Bloomberg yesterday talking about the
insanity of the green New Deal being
proposed by Democrats which would cost
some fifty trillion dollars over ten
years outlaw cars and cut the military
in half here is Michael Bloomberg taking
that apart I think it's time
as a party that we started putting some
meat on the bone and laying out exactly
how a green New Deal shouldn't what it
should include and I believe that that
plan should be bold and ambitious and
most importantly achievable I'm a little
bit tired of listening to things that
are pie in the sky that we never are
gonna pass I'm never gonna afford I
think it's just disingenuous to promote
those things you've got to do something
that's practical so obviously what he is
saying is true Democrats are not afraid
of Bloomberg why because if somebody is
inside the Democratic Party they can
easily be marginalized simply through
identity politics this is the plan for
Democrats get the moderates in the room
and then push them off to the fringes
the moderates by using identity politics
and you can see this from the most
passionate of the members of the
Democratic base so there's a former
campaign aide for Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez and Bernie Sanders and this
former campaign aide who's name is
Shaheed he was he came forward and he
was talking about Howard Schultz listen
to the tactics that he was using to try
and marginalize Howard Schultz
regardless of the third party thing I
think it tells you way more about what
white male billionaires think about
themselves that they should be in charge
and I think in this moment in time where
you have all these working-class people
of all backgrounds who've been hurt by
the Trump administration to put another
white male billionaire who is putting
his things the deficit is the biggest
crisis in the country that is ridiculous
given where the electorate is that
people want you know I think Ocasio
cortes one of the reasons she's popular
is because she's a working-class person
from the Bronx we need to see more
leaders like that okay so well lead
shaheed is making the case inside the
Democratic Party and this is precisely
the reason why Howard Schultz should
never run inside the Democratic Party
because the rip on him is gonna be that
he's too rich and too white neither of
which is an argument both of which our
emotional appeals to identity politics
and tribal polarization that's what this
is if you're Howard Schultz you are not
to run inside the Democratic Party if
you're Michael Bloomberg you are crazy
to run inside the Democratic Party you
will be marginalized so quickly it will
make your head spin because you're rich
and you're not a member of a minority
group that matters right Michael
Bloomberg's Jewish but that's not a
minority group that matters you have to
have a certain shade of skin a hue of
skin in order for you to be taken
seriously as a minority inside the
Democratic Party these days now the
reason that all of this matters is
because what Democrats really want to
avoid
is having to moderate their positions
yesterday Kamala Harris had to do just
that so we talked about yesterday on the
program Kamala Harris did a CNN Town
Hall in which she simply spit out that
she wanted to get rid of all private
health insurance in the country
two-thirds of Americans are in some form
of private health insurance and
virtually the entire system rests on
private health insurance employer
guaranteed health insurance employer
benefits , will Harris said she just
wanted to do away with all of it well
yesterday she had to backtrack it now
this was really funny because she went
out in front right she said okay let's
get rid of all private health insurance
and then you saw potential contenders
like senator sherrod Brown of Ohio you
saw him come forward and say yeah I
agree I agree with Connell Harris yeah I
want to do that too and then she just
slowly backed away leaving sherrod Brown
standing there holding the bag of
flaming dog poop that is nationalized
health care so over the last 24 hours
she has backtracked you'll recall that
she said on CNN Town Hall quote I
believe the solution and I actually feel
very strongly about this is that we need
to have Medicare for all that's just the
bottom line now first of all we should
know what they're actually talking about
is not Medicare for all they're talking
about Medicaid for all which is the sort
of poverty based government program that
exists for the very poor in this country
and that shows really not a lot of
evidence of having any sort of serious
impact on the health outcomes of
Americans Jake Tapper pointed out that
you if you like your insurance who
wouldn't get to keep it and Harris said
let's eliminate all of that let's move
on well now Harris is backtracking
CNN reports as the furor grew a Harris
advisor on Tuesday signaled that the
candidate would also be open to the more
moderate health reform plans which would
preserve the industry being floated by
other congressional Democrats it
represents a compromise position that
risks angering Medicare for all
proponents who view eliminating private
health insurance as key to enacting
their comprehensive reform her national
press secretary
Ian Sam's told CNN Medicare for all as
the plan she believes will solve the
problem and get all Americans covered
period she has co-sponsored other pieces
of legislation that she sees as a path
to getting us there but this is the plan
she is running on all of this happened
after a bunch of Democrats came out said
uh this is a bad idea we have many
people in our constituency who like
their health care plans Senator Dick
Durbin who is pretty radical guy himself
from Illinois
this was too radical for him he said it
would take a mighty transition to move
from where we are to that what most of
us said we would support us a Medicare
tight plan a not-for-profit public plan
that is available for everyone
Tim Kaine in Virginia former VP
candidate under Hillary Clinton one of
the most ill-fated political decisions
of all time he said I'm not gonna say
you have to give it up I think the idea
is to offer a nonprofit insurance plan
as an option Senator Dianne Feinstein
who is no moderate she pushed back on
her as she said I'm not there so it's
amazing to watch as as she has to
backtrack by the way Bernie Sanders will
now nuke her as well he should and this
is Bernie's idea and Bernie should come
forward he should say come on Harris
said she would support Medicare for all
but know she's weak indeed and she is
backing off that plan the only true
solution is to have the kind of health
care to have in Cuba and also for me to
sit and sing Soviet anthems shirtless
which is actually a thing that he's now
on tape doing promote the 1980s during
his honeymoon if no joke
so Pamela Harris had to back off all
this stuff why because her positions are
actually unpopular the only way for an
unpopular position to win when it comes
to presidential politics is to pit it
against a more unpopular politician
Democrats want Kamala Harris is program
but they want to lie about it and they
have to lie about it if there is an
alternative Schultz is the alternative
to that and that is what is scaring the
devil out of them so they are attempting
what's amazing is they're treating him
as though he's a typical Democrat and
more more than that they are treating
him the same way they treat any
political opponent if you think that the
Democrats hate President Trump
especially they do a little bit more
than other folks but anyone who opposes
their radical agenda they attack in
exactly the same way so how are you
Donald Trump according to the left a
member of the KKK racist sexist pig at
homophobe now we are getting the exact
same attacks on Howard Schultz a liberal
and this is my favorite attack of the
day this one comes courtesy of The Daily
Beast okay and Sam Stein who is a daily
beast reporter but formerly of
Huffington Post he tweeted this out the
Starbucks music store under Schultz his
tenure was unbelievably painfully white
I'm not kidding you they're now going
through the musical selections at the
Starbucks music store you'll recall that
Starbucks
used to have these they may still have
these CD racks where they sell their
CD's you mean a seattle-based coffee
firm put out white people music
unbelievable shocking you mean you mean
a firm from like the center of the
grunge world an alternative rock put out
a bunch of white people alternative rock
music that's crazy but this is this is
disqualifying obviously if the CDs that
you could buy in Starbucks now forced
upon you but that you have the option to
buy or buy disproportionately white
artists from Seattle
this means that Howard Schultz is a
brutal crisis here's what it says over
at The Daily Beast I kid you not
over 21 years Starbucks released and
sold 262 records using discogs.com
a good percentage of these were
compilations like music for little
hipsters or British folk the single
artist albums though are overwhelmingly
from white musicians
according to review by The Daily Beast
the only living black artist we could
find among the 262 Starbucks releases
were Herbie Hancock mary j blige Sly and
the Family Stone
Al Green beninese singer Angelique Kidjo
and jazz trio soul live Elijah is the
youngest among those she's 48 years old
ah obvious racism racism it must be
stopped because you could only buy
mostly white people music and a mostly
white people coffee shop based in a
mostly white people area Wow
obviously we have to we have to stop
this guy I mean if we don't stop him
he's gonna put y'all back in Chains
right there that that's how this is
gonna go the Democrats have only one
strategy when it comes to marginalizing
their opposition it can't be that their
positions are bad because the Democratic
positions are one hell of a lot worse
the position instead has to be the same
as it always is racist sexist bigoted
homophobe that gets tired really quickly
and that's why anyone who has a moderate
position would be so unbelievably stupid
to run inside the Democratic Party right
now like why would you they're just
going to destroy you based not on your
positions but based on your race based
on your sex and based on your your
wealth status based on your income line
okay in just a second I'm gonna talk
about the increased radicalism of
Democrats at the state level on the
issue of abortion plus a real hit job
that's been put out but on a black
professor at Harvard University it's
really kind of fascinating we'll get to
that in just a second first I want to
talk to you about how
you can save money we are sponsored by
honey it's the smart shopping assistant
that helps you save time and money
opinions are like smartphones
everybody's got one but we can all agree
that getting the best deal is important
when you shop online and you've probably
heard me talk about honey which is an
amazing free browser extension that
automatically helps me save money on all
my favorite sites I wouldn't be doing my
job if I didn't tell you about how honey
makes even Amazon better so I am like an
original Amazon Prime member like I
joined up with Amazon in 1998 okay so
I'm going all the way back you know much
money I have saved on Amazon because of
honey a lot in fact my latest purchase I
bought honey using honey I am not
kidding because when you buy anything on
Amazon there's a good shot that you're
not getting the best deal unless you're
also using honey here's the way it works
with millions of sellers on Amazon using
the same products the only way to know
if you're getting the best price is to
use honey because honey's best price
finder automatically compares the prices
of millions of sellers that carry the
item that you want honey even factors in
shipping sales tax and Amazon Prime
status to make sure that you're getting
the lowest total price it shows you the
best deal every time even if Amazon
doesn't it's like having a smart
shopping assistant next time you're
shopping on Amazon treat yourself to the
free upgrade that guarantees you always
get the absolute best price add honey
for free at join honey calm slash Ben
that is join honey calm slash man I
literally bought honey
using honey join a honey calm slash man
honey is the smart shopping assistant to
helps you save time and money why would
you waste your money just go do it
it makes perfect sense all right
meanwhile the Democrats are moving in an
increasingly radical direction when it
comes to abortion and it's frightening
honestly it's frightening we're now
living in a world where the Democrats
have decided to full-scale embrace the
most extreme version of pro-abortion law
there used to be a time when Democrats
were in favor of safe legal and rare
that is not a thing anymore safe legal
and rare is not a thing for Democrats
the only thing they care about now is
the ability to kill babies up two points
of birth and this is not an exaggeration
this is a basic obvious truth I'm not
the one who's even saying it there's a
Virginia bill that is now set to
legalize abortion all the way to points
of birth it was introduced by Democratic
delegate Cathy Tran in Virginia when
questioned about the bill on Monday by a
Republican delegate named Todd Gilbert
the Virginia House Majority Leader
acknowledged it would allow abortion
even at the
and of pregnancy when a woman was going
into labor so the woman is going into
labor at 37 weeks of pregnancy and you
can plunge a knife into the back of the
baby's head and kill it
under this bill okay here's this lady
acknowledging exactly that it's pretty
astonishing how late in the third
trimester could a physician perform an
abortion if he indicated it would impair
the mental health of the of the woman or
physical health okay okay I'm talking
about the mental health so I mean
through the third trimester the third
trimester goes all the way up to 40
weeks okay but to the end of the third
trimester I don't think we have a limit
in the bill so where it's obvious that a
woman is about to give birth she has
physical signs of that she is about to
give a birth would that still be a point
at which she could request an abortion
if she was so certified she's dilating
my bill would allow that yes this is
infanticide there's no other way to put
it that is infanticide if you believe
that the ten centimeters between the
dilation of the cervix and the exit of
the separate human being from the womb
is all that defines humanity you are
insane this is full scale support of
infanticide and it's now being backed by
Virginia Democrat Virginia Democrats
another New York Democrats on California
Democrats and I Massachusetts Democrats
Virginia Democrats in New York this is
already become legal you there at least
seven states where you can now abort a
baby all the way up till point of birth
well I mean this is utterly on
controversial stuff we are not talking
about a we're not talking about a
fertilized embryo we're not talking
about an egg that was fertilized three
days ago and whether or not you should
be able to get a morning-after pill okay
well we are talking about now is a fully
formed human baby in every aspect every
aspect of this baby is completely formed
this is infanticide this is human
sacrifice to mola I mean this is this is
like biblically enjoined and the only
reason I cite the Bible is because the
Bible was enjoining actual child
sacrifice this is actual child sacrifice
if for the mental health of the woman
you believe that you can cut a baby
apart in the womb that is fully alive
this is this is insane okay but this is
how far the Democratic Party has moved
in order to fight back against
Republicans who say that life should be
preserved the position Democrats have
taken is that the end of life
is to be celebrated the ending of a life
that is not your own even is to be
celebrated and it's not just in Virginia
the Rhode Island governor has now
signaled that she is willing to go
forward with all of this
according to Michael build her over at
life news.com Rhode Island governor Gina
Raimondo who is purportedly Catholic she
is pushing a radical pro-abortion bill
the legislation would legalize abortions
for any basically any reason up to birth
a State House committee is expected to
vote on the bill as of today earlier
this month romanzo promised to support
the pro-abortion bill in her State of
the Union State of the State address
according to NBC 10 she said let's make
this the year we codify women's access
to reproductive health care here in
Rhode Island ok this is a war on human
life and this is in fact a war on
religious practice ok this is because
let's be clear about the next step here
it's not just about the killing of the
unborn which should be gross and
horrifying enough what this is going to
result in is the state telling doctors
that they must perform these abortions
or lose their medical license this is
where this is going
Obamacare contraceptive mandates were
already moving in this direction there
was all even in the state of California
you're allowed right now to refer out to
other providers who provide an abortion
but I believe you must do so I believe
that you're supposed to I want to check
the law in the state of California but
last I checked I believe that the law in
the state of California is if your
religious practitioner if you are an
OBGYN in the state of California who
doesn't perform abortions and a woman
comes in and says I want an abortion you
must by law refer her to somebody who
will provide that abortion I believe if
it's not that way it soon will be
because that is what Democrats want
Democrats are radical on these issues
this is not in line with the American
with what the American people want but
the effect of American politics is now
resulting in substantive change what I
mean by this is that the hatred that
both members of both parties feel from
one another is leading to actual policy
radicalization it used to be that people
in each party you know even though they
disagreed with each other didn't really
hate each other on the deep root level
that members of the parties now despise
one another and what that meant is that
you were at least grant a you'd at least
grant the Britain the basic humanity of
the person with whom you were talking
then you have a conversation with
somebody if you ever wish to reach any
sort of agreement or even to be in the
same room with them you have to assume
good intentions it's something I've been
working on in my own life and in my own
career trying to assume good intentions
of people with whom I disagree but if
the other person doesn't assume good
intentions on your behalf if they assume
that your positions are driven by animus
that is going to lead them to reject
your positions and take the exact polar
opposite position so for example if the
people on the left with regard to
abortion assumed that people who are
pro-life simply want to preserve the
life of infants even if they disagree
then maybe they would respond by saying
okay well what's a reasonable way to
define life and then we could have an
argument over that I would still be
pro-life and I would still think that
the pro-abortion side is wrong but at
least then you can have a conversation
that is steeped in science and not
steeped in insulting the other side if
however pro-choicers believe that
pro-lifers simply want to control the
bodies of women and are ensconced in a
fight to be tyrannical Handmaid's Tale
purveyors well then their reaction is
going to be well any attempts to limit
abortion access is really about
controlling a body of women and we can't
have that so let's just legalize
abortion all the way up till birth in
other words when you start assuming bad
faith on the part of the other side it
leads you directly away from moderation
you can see the Democrats doing this
with Howard Schultz and Howard Schultz
was one of them until he wasn't and now
that he's not one of them they're
castigating him as badly motivated until
five minutes ago Howard Schultz was a
good guy the kind of guy who wasn't
gonna put Christmas colors on Starbucks
cups and who's going to ensure that
bathrooms would be available to all
without purchase in Starbucks stores
then he walked outside the party line
and now he is an evil rich white
billionaire terrible terrible person now
which means all of his positions can be
thrown out as well the reliance of
Democrats on the belief in the bad
intent of their political opponents
that's what's driving this
radicalization right now so we may think
that it's just about you know fraying
the social fabric but there are actual
policy ramifications to all of this if
you cross the line politically for
Democrats then many folks on the Left
will immediately assume you are now a
bad person and that means there can be
no moderation there can be no
negotiation it is over in just a second
we're going to talk about where the
Republican Party stands in all of this
but first
let's talk about how you make your
business better this year well hiring
can be pretty time-consuming you posted
jobs to several online job boards only
you get tons of the wrong resumes then
you have to sort through all those
resumes just to find a few people with
the right skills and experience those
job sites that overwhelm you with the
wrong resumes those are not smart that's
why you should do the smart thing and go
to zip recruit comm slash daily wire
right zip recruiter finds qualified
candidates for you they're powerful
matching technology scans thousands of
resumes to identify people with the
right skills education and experience
and then actively invites them to apply
to your job so you get qualified
candidates incredibly fast which is why
zip recruiter is rated number one by
employers across the United States that
rating comes from hiring sites on
Trustpilot with over 1000 reviews and
right now you get a special deal my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
again that is zip recruiter com
slash daily Wire Dai ly WI re zip
recruiter com slash daily wire there's
legitimately no reason for you not to do
this when you're hiring we use it here
at daily wire to constantly upgrade our
staff go check it out zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest way to hire ok we're gonna
get to more of the more of the
Republican versus Democrat battle and an
astonishing story out of Harvard where a
prominent black professor is now I think
being railroaded over really skimpy me
to charges we'll talk about that in just
a second first you have to go subscribe
all you have to do is subscribe you
spend $9.99 a month that's it that's um
that's all you have to do $9.99 a month
ok and then you get access to my show
and not just my show the other two hours
that we do later in the day we are
providing you so much content it is
making my fingers bleed I mean then
that's just it's incredible I'm sitting
here typing out all the things I'm gonna
do later today and it's gonna be unreal
but you're not gonna be there for it
unless you're a subscriber also when you
subscribe for $99 a year you get this
the very greatest in all beverage
vessels the leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr now you may have noticed that
I've been ill lately why well because
over the weekend I didn't have my tumblr
I didn't use my tumblr over the weekend
more fool me if only I had used it I
would have been immune to the disease
running rampant through my family yes we
all had the flu shot ok go check it out
the leftist here's hot or cold tumblr
that is available with your annual
subscription for 99 dollars a year also
a few
more announcements we have a new date a
new time you may have noticed that last
night we did not in fact do a daily
we're backstage so if you were waiting
with bated breath where are where are my
friends why are they not here with me
well we were all at home relaxing next
week we will moppy our next episode of
daily wire backstage has been
rescheduled for the evening of February
5th Nancy Pelosi canceled our daily wire
backstage and then we had to reschedule
it for February 5th because that's the
State of the Union address daily wire
god-king jeremy boring me Andrew Klavan
the execrable michael knowles and his
terrible bowtie and alicia Kraus will be
here discussing all the important issues
and of course answering your questions
when we finally see president Trump
deliver the State of the Union will he
deliver it like a baby tune in on
Tuesday to find out as always only daily
why our subscribers get to ask questions
so make sure to subscribe today also do
not forget my latest book the right side
of history I'm doing the audio read
right now and I am so excited about this
book like really this is the most
excited I've ever been about the release
of any of my books I'm really proud of
this I think it's deeply important I
think it's a great primer on what
Western civilization is all about and
why we need to defend it I mean it
really is like a 2500 year history of
Western civilization I like it I think
it's good it's called the right side of
history it's coming out March 19th you
can head over to right side of history
book com2 pre-order right now pre-sales
are live with your help we'll hit the
bestseller list which would be awesome
because why not hit the bestseller list
with something substantive you know not
like Marie Kondo and bringing you joy
and such like something that actually is
going to teach you about the roots of
our civilization go check that out also
you shouldn't subscribe at YouTube and
iTunes when you do then you also get
access to our something special this
Sunday we have on the amazing and Dave
Ramsey this is a great conversation I
can't wait for you to see it there's a
little bit of a preview hey guys I'm
Dave Ramsey this Sunday I will be on the
Ben Shapiro show the Sunday special hey
we're gonna talk about life we're gonna
talk about money it's rich don't miss it
everybody's a great guy and you're gonna
want to be part of that conversation is
pretty fantastic so go check out all of
those things so much for you to do okay
I need you to pick up my book I need you
to subscribe and I need you to subscribe
at YouTube and iTunes and leave us a
review because you're part of our gang
and we really appreciate it
we're the gang that carries around books
while we whistle and snap our fingers
like it like the Jets and the Sharks
except we're carrying around you know
copies
of Dante in the Bible and such ok go
check it out we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the country
[Music]
so breaking news breaking news turtle
has suck at their jobs and I have to
bring this up because this is
legitimately breaking as we're on the
air right now
so you remember yesterday we discussed a
story this was the story of unfortunate
Empire actor jussie Smollett trusty
Smollett is black and gay and he alleged
according to TMZ that he was walking
along the streets of Chicago the mean
streets of Chicago at 2:00 a.m. when
suddenly out of nowhere this is
according to TMZ they say a friend of
Smollett said this or somebody close to
Smollett which probably means knowing
that this person Smollett reported he
was walking down those mean streets of
Chicago when suddenly two white men in
two white men emerged from the shadows
carrying a noose and bleach proceeded to
throw the noose around his neck precede
ins who call him the n-word and also the
F word for gay people pour bleach all
over him and then shout at him that this
was Magga country in Chicago at 2:00
a.m. in 60-degree below freezing weather
they were just like hanging out on the
street waiting for an obscure actor from
a show that is I'm sure highly popular
among the magg a crowd by the way as you
loved the implication that the people in
Madinah country that their favorite
shows Empire you just know okay no I
mean if the implication is that Magga
people are racist I'm pretty sure
they're not tuning into Empire every
single week to find Jesse Smollett in
any case this guy alleges this and then
Chicago PD says okay well in the
original report we didn't have any
evidence and so that and then the story
gets weirder apparently they just sort
of let him go after bringing a noose and
bleach and yelling at him that this was
Magga country they allegedly broke a rib
and then he somehow got out of there and
he didn't call an ambulance
and he didn't call for the police to
actually pursue anyone he just sort of
sauntered over to the hospital he drove
himself to the hospital and then he
reported something to police no I don't
know what happened and you don't know
what happened but neither the police
know what happened the original report
from the police is that Smollett had not
told them about the manga country
comments only TMZ had it
TMZ stood by its report then later the
Chicago PD backtracked and they said oh
yeah we called up Smollett and we asked
him
it he said oh yeah that happened by the
way which I mean if I had to speculate
that sounds a lot like somebody who told
the story to TMZ that was a lot more
sensational than the story he told the
police because the original story he
told the police did not have the race of
the suspect or the magg a country
comment which is just I got mugged on
the streets of Chicago which is like
everyone in Chicago
pretty much every day but the story told
the TMZ is a lot more salacious okay so
he tells that story or somebody tells
that story to TMZ the Chicago PD don't
get that story then they call for
follow-up and he says well yeah by the
way they were white and they were
shouting magnet country so all of this
is weird now here's what the Chicago PD
are reporting this is according to the
Associated Press quote Chicago Police
say they've reviewed hundreds of hours
of footage from downtown surveillance
cameras but haven't found footage yet of
the alleged attack on Empire actor Jesse
Smollett weird how weird the department
said in a news release late Tuesday that
detectives reviewed footage from
privately owned cameras near where
Smollett says he was attacked and will
broaden their search by reviewing
footage from traffic cameras and public
bus cameras Smollett told police he was
walking downtown near the Chicago River
at about 2:00 a.m. on Tuesday when two
masked men hurled racial and homophobic
slurs at him beat him through an unknown
substance on him and put a rope around
his neck the 36 year old actor whose
black and gay and plays the gay
character Jamal Lyon on the Fox
television show took himself to
Northwestern Memorial Hospital for
treatment Empire a shot in Chicago and
is currently in production by the way
the police said that they had tape of
him leaving the store where he was
shopping at 2:00 a.m. but no tape of
what happened just outside the store so
they've reviewed hundreds of hours of
tape and they come up with nothing nada
weird so maybe this happened just the
way this guy's had to happen maybe or
maybe this was a story that was too good
to be true and the media jumped on it
and they decided to make it a national
issue without any evidence and none
supportable by the police now you don't
even good if the journalist had simply
waited for all the facts to come out
like if they had the headlines yesterday
from the media where things like Empire
actor beaten and beaten and and
victimized by slurs and by Magga fans
that was like the TMZ headline mentioned
the magazine and then
there was no backtrack what it should
have said is actor says bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla then it's true but pretty
pretty amazing stuff pretty amazing
stuff so well done journalists as always
you have that you have made clear your
narrative structure just well done we'll
wait for all the details to come out
maybe it all happened the way this guy
said it went down so far there's no
evidence and I think that all of the
questions that were being asked about
this story initially still remain kind
of puzzling this is Chicago who runs
around Chicago going mrs. Magda country
111 percent of people in Chicago voted
against Donald Trump in 2016
yeah I can't think of a place that it's
less mega country than downtown Chicago
legitimately what the okay so that's
that meanwhile Republicans are having
their own problems so Texas Republicans
are reporting that come 2020 they're
afraid they're gonna lose the state they
should be afraid they're gonna lose the
state given beta it works very strong
showing against Ted Cruz in the last
senatorial election Texas GOP chairman
James Dickey has delivered a message to
the Trump campaign the Republican
National Committee GOP donors and
activists in the state
nationally Republican operatives and
donors have historically taken Texas for
granted they've directed their financial
and organizational muscle to more
competitive regions this is according to
the Washington Examiner separately
Senator John Cornyn of Texas who's up
for re-election next year has spoken
with the new RNC co-chairman Tommy Hicks
about concerns that Trump could actually
lose the state Texas is the is the
election I mean if Texas if Trump loses
Texas the election is over
of course if Trump loses Michigan and
Pennsylvania or Michigan and Wisconsin
or pass or Pennsylvania and Wisconsin
then he loses the election as well the
president really has a narrow path here
to 270 if he loses Texas he's done and
infra publicans lose Texas in a 20/20
election matchup Ben's has not bode well
for the future of the Republican Party
in the country I mean Texas is about as
red a state as it is possible to have
now listen they had some structural
disadvantages in 2016 they got blown out
in the suburbs
Trump is deeply unpopular in the suburbs
Republicans are gonna have to face some
basic facts when it comes to Trump 2020
they're gonna have to face the fact that
Donald Trump does not actually have a
massive group of people who are secretly
hiding in the shadows and who are going
to emerge to vote for him that isn't
what happened in 2016 it wasn't a bunch
of people who lied to pollsters what
happened in 2016 is everybody on the
Left thought Hillary was going to win
and everybody on the left didn't like
her so they didn't show up
Donald Trump won because they didn't
show up in 2018 Republicans showed up at
better than 2016 levels and they got
blown out by eight point six points on
average across the country Democrats all
showed up if Republicans want to win in
2020 they have to appeal to those
suburban voters this by the way is the
real reason that many Republicans are
fond of Howard Schultz his candidacy
what they're hoping is that he does in
fact draw away those suburban voters
from the Democrats and split the vote
and Trump's support base is pretty solid
it's not going anywhere
Schultz isn't gonna carve into that
support base but the other option here
is for Trump to do what Democrats should
be doing which is appeal to that
suburban vote base now President Trump
is a DoubleDown guy there's a guy who
dances with the gal that brung him not
his personal life but certainly in
politics he's the guy who who if he
believes that his manner of politics won
him election he's not gonna change it
now but here is the truth you do need to
change strategies at a certain point if
you don't change strategies while all
the indicators are pointing south you're
being foolish and president Trump has an
opening the Democrats are incredibly
radical all president Trump has to do is
be the nicest version of himself doesn't
mean change himself but be the nicest
version of himself and say it's funny
when he talk to folks who know President
Trump on a one-to-one level what they
will say is that in person on a 1:1
level he is charming he is generous he's
very nice to people and then you get him
in a group and he changes radically he
wants to dominate he wants to be the
Alpha in the room you know a softer side
to Trump would be such a shock to the
American people I'm not sure the
American psyche could stand it if
President Trump had any appeal for
suburban voters he would clean up in
2020 instead he's busy alienating the
very voters he needs in order to win
election there's an opening for him here
but he's gonna need to take it now one
of the big problems here again as I
mentioned earlier is that people are so
polarized by Trump that they're
embracing positions they wouldn't
otherwise embrace and that's
particularly true among young people
there's a new poll out from Axios and
SurveyMonkey showing that warmth toward
socialism has grown particularly amongst
the young this is
largely the effect of media coverage but
it is partially the effect of a reaction
to President Trump some 29% of
Republicans aged 18 to 34 said that they
are positive toward socialism toward the
word socialism which should scare the
living daylights out of everyone one of
my concerns about President Trump in
2016 is that Trump would be so
polarizing that he would end up smearing
a lot of Republican causes with his
unpopularity President Trump needs to do
better he needs to do better he needs to
actually explain issues and if he can't
do it he needs to shut up and let others
do it the same Axio SurveyMonkey poll
shows that 31% of Young Republicans say
inequality is a bigger problem than
over-regulation of the free market 39%
of Young Republicans want the feds to do
more to reduce the gap between the rich
and the poor this is not good news for
Republicans Republicans are trending
toward Democratic positions independents
are trending toward Democratic positions
now Democrats are trending too far left
but that doesn't mean that Republicans
don't in fact have a problem they do
they're not making the case and because
they're not making the case they're
losing and let's let's be real about
this weekend we can yell as much as we
want about Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax
and Kamala Harris is wild proposals on
guns and and green new deals and all the
rest
if Republicans aren't making an
affirmative case for their own belief
system they've got a problem this is it
look president Trump is by nature a
counter-puncher
and it's useful and that's a useful
skill but when you're the president you
should be a bulldozer when you're the
president you actually need to be using
that bully pulpit you can't just sit
behind you can't be Floyd Mayweather
binghams offensive president whose
excellent at defending and deflecting
punches again useful skill but you
better have a right
you better have a heavy right and so far
President Trump has not had a heavy
right when it comes to pushing positions
that Republicans care about he's been
getting things done but getting things
done is not enough to shift the country
the president has two jobs one is to
implement policy and the other is to
make the case to the American people
about why his policies are best and why
his ideology is best this is why all the
talk about having a pragmatic president
and pragmatically minded president is so
much silliness the most influential
presidents in American history have
really not been chiefly about policy
they've been chiefly about shifting the
way the
people thought I'm thinking purport
really hear of three presidents in the
20th century Woodrow Wilson FDR and
Ronald Reagan those were the three
presidents who did the most to shift how
Americans thought Barack Obama tried to
do that he didn't really succeed Donald
Trump isn't even trying to do that and
that needs to change immediately and if
he's incapable of educating the American
people
he needs to point to people who are
capable of educating the American people
because if they if the American people
aren't educated toward conservative
positions they're not going to embrace
those positions they're just going to
embrace whoever is the most magnetic
hands in it and then we have cult of
personality politics which is the
opposite of what conservatism would
recommend okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like today there's a great
new memoir it's gonna be out by a guy
named Saurabh Amari he is the opinion
editor over at the New York Post
formerly of commentary magazine it's a
memoir of his journey from being a an
Iranian Muslim to being a to being a
Catholic the book is called from fire by
water my journey Catholic to the
Catholic faith as you know I am NOT a
Catholic I'm not a Christian I'm an
Orthodox Jew this is a moving book about
why it is the Western civilization is
based on certain fundamental religious
principles and more importantly it's a
great study in comparative culture and
there are a lot of people in the United
States who have never studied any
culture other than their own and so they
believe that America is bad because
America in a vacuum you look at all of
its flaws and you think of this this
place
it's got serious problems and then you
look at America as compared to other
places on earth and you realize this
place is pretty fantastic this place is
pretty great by the way I felt the same
about Los Angeles before I went to
Boston well I've lived my entire life in
Los Angeles and I just think la Penna
dingy people are kind of shallow you
know LA and then I went to Boston where
it is winter 9 months of the year it's
the worst and I came back to Lima look
this place is great the sort of a
horrible Mary's book is basically about
that except with America and other
countries well worth the read from fire
by water my journey to the Catholic
faith also it's an amusing fun read
quick read I read it in one sitting SAR
by Mary's book go pre-order it right now
it's quite good okay time for a thing
that I hate
a couple of things that I hate there's a
news story out from The Wall Street
Journal today talking about how the
White House may soon be making
concessions to Dianne Feinstein and
Kamala Harris about appointing leftist
judges to the Ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals here is what the Wall Street
Journal story says and says president
Trump's best achievement has arguably
been judicial selection from the Supreme
Court to the appellate circuits to
district court nominees he is remaking
the federal courts so more than a few
eyes widened this month when the White
House omitted three names from the list
of 50 judges mr. Trump sent back to the
Senate what entry gives the three
missing names were Californians
nominated to the Ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals last year to other Ninth Circuit
nominees Eric Miller of Washington and
Bridget bought a bait of Arizona were
renowned nated but the annual Collins
Kenneth Lee and Patrick kumite were
withheld because the White House is
negotiating with Dianne Feinstein and
Kamala Harris miss Feinstein and the
White House counsel's office have been
pen pals on this for some time
in a November letter to new White House
Counsel Pat chip alone miss Feinstein
and Miss Harris requested that the White
House work with us to reach an agreement
on a consensus package of nominees the
Democrats want to pick one name from the
White House list one from their own and
a third consensus nominee why in the
world would the White House agree with
this why in the world would they do this
they're suggesting that maybe they're
doing this to buy the support for a
nominee to replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg
are they insane are they insane if the
White House is doing this they must be
off their rockers if they believe that
Kamala Harris or Dianne Feinstein will
hold by any deal that allows them to
vote for a conservative replacement for
Ruth Bader Ginsburg out of their mind
first of all if Ruth Bader Ginsburg dies
in the next two years there will be
riots in this country over the Supreme
Court there will be because Democrats
are not going to stand for an actual
swing vote moving to the right this is
why they're already writing that there
are they writing eulogies for her in
movies right they're already doing
movies like on the basis of sex which
looks more boring than any movie other
than like actual drying of paint on film
they're making full hay geographies of
Ruth Bader Ginsberg the notorious RBG if
she dies while Trump is in office all
hell will break loose you really think
you're gonna count on Dianne Feinstein
and Kamala Harris to come to your aid in
this mr. president my goodness this
would be so stupid this is Trump's big
it's his biggest accomplishment he blows
it it will be a massive massive fail
okay meanwhile another thing that I hate
today
so there's a piece today by Stuart
Taylor of real clear investigations
about the takedown of Roland fryer jr.
excuse me and I've mentioned Professor
fryer before on the program he did a
study last year all about police
violence against black folks he came up
with the conclusion that in fact black
folks were not shot as often as white
folks in similar situations by the
police which was a controversial finding
well now fryer is under fire here's what
real clear investigations reports in a
December 14th 2018 piece the New York
Times set the stage by noting in its
opening sentences that Roland fryer jr.
had attained tenure at Harvard received
a MacArthur Genius grant and won the
most prestigious award for a young
American economist in the second
paragraph came the takedown but his
rapid ascent has taken a troubling turn
its Harvard officials review a
university investigators conclusion that
dr. fryer fostered a work environment
hostile to women one filled with sexual
talk and bullying this article and
Harvard's office for dispute resolution
have made a near pariah of the youngest
black professor ever tenured at Harvard
a man Borden's poverty who is still much
admired among many former female and
male subordinates and other people who
know him well and who seen the attacks
on him is tinged with racism and me to
overreaction he is also admired among
experts for his pioneering scholarship
on how best to educate poor and minority
children and other racial and gender
issues in an article Leonard with sins
against on his journalism The Times
vastly overstated the criticism of fryer
in a confidential 81 page November
report by the office of dispute
resolution which has a staff of ten
eight women and two men the report seems
subtly and skillfully biased against a
man who Modi are branded a sexual
harasser for among other things the kind
of off-color jokes and teasing of both
male and female subordinates that more
risk-averse bosses avoid but at least
made clear that fryer 41 has never been
accused of making a pass at a
subordinate or asking for sex the 2600
word times article did not so that this
is a long report about exactly how it is
that the odr at Harvard blew it and how
they overestimated the amount of
terrible terrible things that fryer did
he denies the most obvious accusations
and yet
that was enough from the New York Times
to run this hit piece trying to destroy
him the reason that I think fryer is
being targeted realistically speaking is
because fryer is not a deep partisan you
know fryer happens to be somebody who
performs research that sometimes sides
with the left and sometimes sides with
the right but the process has been
deeply flawed and deeply unfair because
that is the way that it works at these
universities the accusation is
tantamount to to the acquisition itself
is tantamount to condemnation it's
pretty astonishing the lawyers for fryer
say that the case has been racially
biased as well as procedurally fraught a
flawed fry wrote to a friend and later
shared a letter stating thirty years
after watching my father be sentenced to
eight years in prison because of a he
say she say type encounter with a white
woman in Texas with no physical evidence
I am fighting every day to prove I am
innocent of allegations that threaten
the work I have devoted my life to
Sullivan his lawyer told me that the
office of dispute resolution weighted
the credibility of white witnesses far
above mine or minority witnesses the
main complaint against fryer is white
and then in the absence of real data the
process used racial stereotypes as an
example he cited the office of dispute
resolutions disparagement of the
credibility of Taniya Devi who was
present from any of the allegedly
harassing comments insisting she saw no
harassment she spoke very highly of
fryer
although the investigator in ODR praised
the credibility of the complainants the
white roommate they tended to dismiss
Davies death EES I witness recollections
of what she saw and heard at the labs
now is this racism or is this political
bias whatever it is it is clear that the
sort of kangaroo courts that happen at
these universities have no relationship
really no relationship with due process
of law me too is fine but we're actually
gonna need evidence of things so you
know I I think this deserves a full
airing and I think later on the show
when I have a little bit more time later
today on the show we're gonna go through
the full accusations against fryer and
the takedown because this is well worth
discussing why it is that on today's
college campuses we are willing to run
people out of business simply based on
allegations alone without any serious
evidence to suggest that the allegations
are even damning already well we will be
back here later today for two more hours
be there or be square I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the bench Bureau Show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19